don't forget just a few months ago
not very long ago
senate democrats the biden
administration and the government of
chancellor merkel in germany all came
together to say drop the sanctions on
putin on on the russian nordstrom 2
pipeline because they all said this may
encourage him
uh if we if we squeeze him too much he's
going to lash out well obviously they
were wrong and they completely got it
upended and so the sanctions should have
been put on
or stayed on we should say but the the
democrats the binding administration
should have
kept that pressure on and i think that
we would have a different scenario but
when putin is looking at afghanistan and
by the way people are not talking enough
about the the
policy that biden put in place to drop
the houthis from the terrorist watch
list
as soon as they did that dave we had
a couple of months later what did the
houthis do
they were bombarding the uae abu dhabi
was receiving missiles from the houthis
now this was by official washington
largely ignored there wasn't a
correlation made between hey you know
joe biden and the biden administration
all the democrats just took the houthis
off the terrorist list and what happened
they started acting like terrorists and
so
you you literally have to um push
official washington to see that these
weak policies translate globally into
terrible situations
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the former u.s ambassador to germany as
well as the former acting director of
national intelligence for these great at
least great for now
united states of america and my friend
and californian we're gonna have to get
into that rick grinnell welcome back to
the reuben report
dave thanks for having me always a
pleasure
let's just do the california thing quick
in one minute what the high hell are you
doing there still man i love this place
i can't leave i can't abandon it um it's
bad um look today's the filing deadline
for uh people running for governor
senate congressional races all the races
doesn't look like we're going to have
any major candidate running against
newsom
uh and i think that's just more of a
commentary on the fact that the system
here is broken they do mail-in ballots
uh democrats completely rule this place
like a third world country and so
therefore we really don't have
uh competition
you know rick i knew it was bad in cali
when i was calling people to say i was
leaving and i thought you were going to
be the one guy because you were trying
to clean up the rolls there and you're
still trying to do a whole bunch of
stuff and i know how much you love
california you've been there forever uh
but i was calling people to say i'm
leaving and and everyone was like oh
great you know you should go it's time
to go get out of dodge and you i we're
the only person i thought was gonna say
stay and you go
i get it and then i was like all right
i'm outta here by the way rick every
time i mention california on the show i
put money into this jar and at the end
of the year i'm gonna be handing a whole
bunch of cash and i'm throwing in a
couple thousand dollars in my money for
somebody for somebody that's willing to
leave california and migrate to florida
so i thought i thought you were going to
say for somebody who needs to help pay
taxes because they stayed there and so
i'll gladly take the money no i am not
paying your taxes to king newsom uh okay
but let's let's get on to the stuff that
i i really wanted to talk to you about
this week because obviously there's this
whole russia ukraine situation
um
this is what you're an expert in as an
ambassador and on the intelligence side
and all of that so i thought maybe we
could start by just doing a little uh a
little 101 on what you think
american foreign policy should be like
so before we just jump into before we
get into the specifics of what's
happening in russian ukraine just
generally what you think america's role
in the world should be and maybe how it
was
when uh when you were working with that
orange guy versus how it is now let's
just start there and then we'll jump to
the specifics yeah look you know i think
that um the america first policy is a
fantastic one and it doesn't mean
america alone and it doesn't mean
uh just simply that we bring troops home
and we ignore
uh crises around the world i think what
america first means
is just that is that we put america
first we think about our u.s national
security that's the criteria
what is good for us national security
but it also means that our allies have
to stand up and we encourage them to do
so so it's why we we removed our us
troops in somalia because we said to
kenya hey can you kind of police your
own neighborhood it's why we wanted the
europeans to do more
and i i think there's an admission a
tacit admission from the germans right
now in terms of their policy
that uh they believe that they were on
the wrong track for 10 16 years of
merkel they now are completely flipped
they're better than the senate democrats
they're better than
joe biden because there's an admission
now that wow not paying your nato fair
share of two percent was a huge mistake
so what did the germans do
they decided to say we're going to pay
it all at once in one year to catch up
this is a huge admission that they have
been on the wrong track for 16 years
then they turn around and they say we
got to stop this russian pipeline
this is historic this is unprecedented
don't forget just a few months ago
not very long ago senate democrats the
biden administration and the government
of chancellor merkel in germany all came
together to say drop the sanctions on
putin on on the russian nordstrom 2
pipeline because they all said this may
encourage him
uh if we if we squeeze him too much he's
going to lash out well obviously they
were wrong
and they completely got it
upended and so the sanctions should have
been put on
or stayed on we should say but the the
democrats the binding administration
should have
kept that pressure on and i think that
we would have a different scenario but
when putin is looking at afghanistan and
by the way people are not talking enough
about the the
policy that biden put in place to drop
the houthis from the terrorist watch
list
as soon as they did that day that we had
a couple of months later what did the
houthis do
they were bombarding the uae abu dhabi
was receiving missiles from the houthis
now this was by official washington
largely ignored there wasn't a
correlation made between hey you know
joe biden and the biden administration
all the democrats just took the houthis
off the terrorist list and what happened
they started acting like terrorists and
so you you literally have to um push
official washington to see that these
weak policies translate globally into
terrible
situations
i don't think it's too much to say that
joe biden's weakness is causing
war
scandal
uh destruction
and and we have to be able to shake the
senate democrats because the germans now
see that
uh and it's i never thought i would see
it in my day and they're certainly not
saying rick grinnell was right donald
trump was right but they're coming awful
close so let's stick with that germany
situation for a minute because so you
were ambassador to germany under trump
and if you listen to the media
throughout all of that
um you know trump was mean and scaring
people all the time and you went in
there and you weren't listening to
anybody and the other ambassador wasn't
happy with you and all of this stuff
however
things were basically working in terms
of all of our international agreements
and we were at least
trying to encourage people to pay a bit
more which as you just said now they're
catching up with
did everything shift overnight basically
once
once biden took over
i think that there's a combination of
once biden took over and once merkel was
gone it was relatively at the same time
and you know merkelism really didn't
work we had 16 years of and and i'm
passionate about this subject is that i
believe that chancellor merkel in making
her policy germany first
she decided to move the german
uh
transatlantic relationship away from the
west instead of making a western-facing
alliance where you stand with the west
and you do things uh that benefit the
west
she decided to have a foreign policy
like switzerland and be everybody's
friend and to sell cars you know in
moscow and beijing and tehran and
everywhere else and and don't forget
when when i arrived in germany
uh i was walking around one day and i
and i walked past this
hotel youth hostel and i looked over and
it was literally i'm not exaggerating
the property of north korea
in the middle of berlin and i went back
to the embassy and i was like what the
hell there's
there's a there's a north korean hotel
youth hostel in the middle of berlin i
mean they're under international
sanctions this is illegal and there and
you know everybody at the state
department was like yeah but i guess
we've allowed that to happen and i said
no no no guessing this is unacceptable
so i took it to chancellor merkel and
you know there were a lot of excuses oh
it's not really us it's it's this
management company and i said i don't
care it's in the middle of berlin shut
it down you're violating u.n sanctions
they eventually shut it down they
weren't happy with me for pointing that
out
but i wasn't happy with them for
violating international sanctions my
point in telling you this is that
they've moved away from the west for 16
years well the german marshall fund has
just applauded them as you know this
great economic power
and yet i think that there's a
difference you can bifurcate the
transatlantic alliance from the western
facing
alliance the western alliance and and
merkel decided to just be a part of this
you know transatlantic alliance which
was not western facing she's the one who
moved germany and europe away from the
west and now i think they're scrambling
to say uh yikes we might have encouraged
war in ukraine if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell